Générique
...
-Bienvenue dans
"Ces idées qui gouvernent le monde".
L'autorité politique
remise en question.
ne fait pas recette.
De partout s'élèvent des voix
pour prôner des sociétés de liberté,
de tolérance, pluriculturelles,
oeuvrant pour la diversité
et le consensus,
magnifiant le présent,
voire l'idolâtrant,
et abrasant le passé.
Bref : du rêve pour chacun,
de la prospérité pour tous,
et la paix universelle.
En somme, une modernité heureuse
qui ne s'embarrasserait
ni des contraintes intérieures,
les violences, les dégradations
de service public,
l'insécurité, les précarités
sociales et financières
et pas plus des aléas extérieurs
avec un enchaînement conflictuel,
le terrorisme, le Covid,
la guerre en Ukraine,
et de nous interroger.
Que peut le politique
dans son essence
comme dans sa pratique
face à ce qu'on pourrait qualifier
de démocratie malheureuse
et de République tumultueuse ?
Un politique dont les serviteurs
n'ont plus nom :
de Gaulle, Churchill,
Clemenceau, Mandela,
Mitterrand, Margaret Thatcher,
Indira Gandhi.
Un politique qui cherche à plaire
en faisant de la communication
l'art de gouverner.
Un politique s'exonérant
de la responsabilité
et du courage de ses actes
pour éviter d'affronter
une doxa bien-pensante
et bien souvent éloignée
des réalités.
Nous examinerons d'abord
et surtout cette autorité politique
défaillante en France,
avec des incursions ailleurs,
parce que partout,
il y a une crise des idées
et des valeurs,
et partout les opinions
et les invectives
font florès sur les réseaux
sociaux.
Pour cette radiographie
d'une chute de l'autorité politique,
je vous présente mes invités.
Manuel Valls,
vous êtes ancien maire,
ancien député,
ancien ministre,
ancien Premier ministre.
Vous nous direz ce que vous faites
aujourd'hui dans le présent.
Anne Lauvergeon,
vous êtes cheffe d'entreprise,
femme politique,
vous avez été secrétaire adjointe
à la présidence de la République,
et présidente
d'un fonds d'investissement, ALP.
Nicolas Baverez,
vous êtes avocat,
économiste, politologue,
chroniqueur au Point et au Figaro.
Julien Aubert, ancien député,
vous êtes vice-président,
- vous voyez,
je vous ai déjà promu -
vice-président des Républicains
et président de Oser la France,
un mouvement où se retrouvent
tous les souverainistes.
Après de Gaulle
et le phénomène
s'est accentué depuis,
on fait la distinction politique
entre servir et habiter
le pouvoir.
Pour nous en tenir
à la France contemporaine
et aux trois dernières secousses
populaires et politiques,
les gilets jaunes,
la réforme et les manifestations
à propos des retraites,
les révoltes de jeunes
avec toutes les violences urbaines
occasionnées,
quel regard et quel jugement
portez-vous
sur l'exercice du pouvoir actuel
en termes d'autorité ?
Manuel Valls.
-Vous commencez fort,
cher Emile Malet.
-On est dans l'actualité.
-Surtout après le panorama
qui porte essentiellement
sur la responsabilité politique
que vous avez présentée
pour cette émission.
Tout pouvoir, aujourd'hui,
dans nos démocraties occidentales,
donc celui-ci n'échappe pas
à la règle,
souffre d'une crise d'autorité.
Elle est sans doute plus
aiguë dans notre pays,
pour des raisons sur lesquelles
on reviendra peut-être,
une nation construite
par l'Etat,
un Etat fort, centralisé,
une vision jacobine,
je dirais, de la société,
qui se sont progressivement
dégradés.
Je rajoute à cela,
on fait aussi
un particularisme français,
pas seulement,
mais avec un affaissement
d'un système politique,
ou en tout cas des partis
qui avaient gouverné par alternance,
notamment sous la 5e République,
et donc une dégradation
qui a laissé un espace ouvert
à des nouvelles formations
politiques,
avec peu d'implantations
locales,
à commencer par celle
du président de la République.
Le président de la République,
qui s'appuie sur une force politique
qui n'a pas d'histoire, de mémoire,
qui n'a pas de racines,
qui a une certaine conception
du rôle
ou de l'absence de rôle
des corps intermédiaires
est évidemment confronté
à une crise politique,
démocratique,
à une crise civique
et à une crise de l'autorité.
-Oui, mais M. Valls,
permettez-moi
de vous faire préciser
quelque chose.
Vous avez été maire
d'une ville de banlieue.
Les révoltes de ces derniers temps
sont des révoltes populaires
qui se sont déroulées
dans les grandes métropoles,
mais aussi dans les banlieues.
Vous avez été ministre
de l'Intérieur
et vous avez eu à gérer
la violence.
Par rapport
à ce qui s'est passé en France,
est-ce que vous considérez
que l'autorité politique
s'est exprimée
à l'occasion de ces événements ?
-En général,
elle s'est exprimée.
Vous évoquez sans doute
les révoltes,
les émeutes, les dégradations,
les mises en cause
de l'autorité publique,
de l'Etat, avec des dégradations
de services publics,
d'écoles, de mairies,
de centres sociaux,
mais aussi de commerces
avec une très grande violence
à l'égard, notamment,
des forces de l'ordre.
J'ai le sentiment qu'après
sans doute un moment d'hésitation,
voire de stupeur,
de surprise par rapport
à ces violences,
l'autorité politique
côté police et côté justice,
elle s'est exprimée,
par la présence massive
des forces de police
et de gendarmerie,
et par les condamnations
qui ont eu lieu après,
mais sitôt passé cet épisode,
les problèmes demeurent,
et la contestation de cette
autorité politique, je dirais même
d'une certaine idée de la France,
je considère que c'est à la fois
une manifestation
contre l'autorité de l'Etat,
mais aussi contre une forme
de vivre ensemble,
contre notre pays,
contre ce qui fait France,
qui fait notre pays,
pour utiliser des mots
déjà très utilisés,
donc un peu dépassés,
mais c'est une manifestation
de haine,
à l'égard de notre pays,
à laquelle nous avons assisté.
C'est-à-dire que les réponses,
elles sont difficiles à trouver,
lourdes, mais passent
par une restauration
et de l'autorité politique
et aussi sur ce qui nous unit
dans notre pays,
ce qui fait
que nous sommes français.
-Julien Aubert,
vous êtes d'accord avec ça ?
Vous pensez
qu'il y a eu une défaillance
de l'autorité politique ?
-Sur la gestion de la révolte...
De l'insurrection des banlieues
et des quartiers,
pour moi, il y a quand même
un aveu de faiblesse,
c'est-à-dire qu'on a laissé
en partie brûler,
par peur du dérapage
qui pourrait nous amener
sur une pente plus délicate,
un peu comme pour les gilets jaunes.
Tant qu'il n'y a pas de décès,
j'avais l'impression
que la priorité,
c'était d'éviter qu'on bascule
dans quelque chose de plus violent.
En même temps,
j'ai eu le sentiment
que l'autorité politique
avait perdu, à un moment,
le contrôle du territoire.
D'ailleurs, des unités de police
qui ont été réquisitionnées
l'ont été un peu à la va-vite,
avec des unités
qui n'étaient pas forcément
formées pour cela,
- le RAID notamment -
avec les conséquences
que cela peut engendrer lorsqu'ils
se retrouvent à faire un métier
qui n'est pas le leur.
Après, il y a, je dirais,
deux sortes d'autorités.
Il y a évidemment
la capacité répressive
et puis la capacité
à faire peur,
parce que
c'est ce qui coûte le moins cher.
En réalité,
si on respecte le pouvoir,
la police,
on n'a pas besoin
d'exercer cette force.
Ce qui m'a inquiété,
c'est qu'on en est arrivé au stade
où on est obligés de mettre
en branle des forces armées,
la police, la gendarmerie,
avec le risque de s'apercevoir
qu'on est incapables
de tenir le terrain.
Pour répondre
à la question
que vous aviez posée à M. Valls,
sur la question de la crise
de l'autorité,
il y a une triple crise :
une crise de l'esprit,
de l'âme et du physique.
Le physique,
c'est l'efficacité.
Les gens constatent les problèmes :
"La démocratie, l'autorité publique,
"ne résout pas mes problèmes."
Une crise de l'esprit :
les gens ne comprennent plus,
ou pas toujours très bien,
la manière dont la démocratie
fonctionne
et critiquent la manière
dont elle fonctionne,
par exemple avec le 49.3.
Une crise de l'âme :
je dirais la plus profonde,
c'est que les gens ne croient plus
que la démocratie
puisse répondre à leurs problèmes
ou ne croient plus
que la promesse républicaine
s'incarne aujourd'hui.
Ces trois crises
font qu'il y a ce malaise
qui ne se limite pas
aux révoltes des rues.
-Anne Lauvergeon.
-Je ne sais pas
si je voulais intervenir,
mais oui, j'ai le sentiment
qu'effectivement, on a une crise,
je dirais morale,
et après,
il y a des problématiques
très matérielles,
et très pratiques,
pour savoir si effectivement,
les forces de l'ordre...
La crise morale, pour moi,
est assez française ou occidentale.
Vous parliez au début
de tous les pays.
Il y a un tas de pays
où l'autorité
est pas vraiment légère.
Ca ne moufte pas,
ça ne bouge pas.
Justement, trouver le bon équilibre
est très complexe.
Je reviendrais sur un point :
tout le 19e siècle
et une grosse partie du 20e siècle,
jusque dans les années 90,
on a parlé du progrès,
tous les politiques
parlaient de progrès.
Il y avait dans l'idée
de faire société ensemble,
l'idée que demain
serait effectivement,
- on sait qu'individuellement,
c'était un peu plus complexe -
mais que globalement,
on a substitué au mot de "progrès"
le mot "innovation".
Il y a ceux qui réussissent
et les autres.
Je pense qu'il faut
qu'on essaie
de refaire société ensemble.
Parler de progrès,
c'est considérer
que demain sera meilleur.
Or, aujourd'hui,
on envoie des messages sur demain
qui sont exactement inverses :
l'écoanxiété,
le changement climatique, etc.,
donc c'est une société
qui est à la fois un peu désespérée,
où toutes les préventions
ne sont pas forcément à l'oeuvre
et où les crises prennent
des aspects extrêmement brutaux.
Le politique est responsable,
bien sûr,
mais je dirais que c'est beaucoup
plus complexe que ça,
avec un Etat qui pour moi,
est un peu en voie de...
Dans le même malaise,
avec un effritement
de l'Etat, je dirais.
Vous regardez, d'abord,
l'Etat s'enlève
des prérogatives
très régulièrement.
Vous avez aujourd'hui une centaine
d'autorités indépendantes
qui régulent des choses
aussi importantes
que l'énergie, le droit,
les moyens de presse,
la télévision, etc.
L'Etat a organisé
une forme d'impuissance
en laissant...
Renaud Denoix de Saint Marc,
qui était secrétaire général
du gouvernement,
puis vice-président
du Conseil d'Etat,
quand il voyait dans une annonce
d'un Conseil des ministres
une nouvelle autorité indépendante,
il disait :
"Le démembrement de l'Etat,
"je ne veux pas assister à ça,
"je fermerai mes oreilles."
C'est vrai que c'était à la mode,
on l'a beaucoup fait,
et on n'a pas réfléchi
à ce que ça voulait dire.
On a aussi un phénomène qui,
je crois,
est à l'oeuvre,
commission de déontologie,
pour le départ des fonctionnaires.
Cela veut dire que si vous voulez
partir dans une entreprise,
vous avez intérêt à partir jeune
et non pas à rester servir l'Etat.
Vous avez donc un appauvrissement
de la substance.
Or on a besoin de faire
une énorme réforme de l'Etat,
on a besoin de simplifier.
Il y a une inspiration forte
de tous les gens
à avoir un service meilleur
pour les impôts qu'ils payent,
ou qu'ils ne payent pas.
Tout ça, on a l'impression
que c'est en friche, en jachère,
alors que la demande
est extraordinairement forte.
On a bien vu que la réponse
du politique
a été de dire :
"On va prendre des cabinets
anglo-saxons pour faire le travail."
Ce n'est pas satisfaisant.
Ce ne sont pas des cabinets
internationaux qui vont savoir
ce que l'Etat doit devenir.
Il y a énorme travail
sur nous-mêmes,
tout le monde le sait,
tout le monde le sent.
-Nicolas Baverez,
vous direz ce que vous pensez
de cet enchaînement
des conflits qu'il a eu en France
et qu'on considère quasiment
comme une normalité,
même si elle est pathologique.
Je voudrais aller plus loin,
en plus, avec vous,
en vous demandant
d'où vient cet affaiblissement
de l'autorité chez nos gouvernants ?
Est-ce qu'à votre avis,
c'est un mésusage constitutionnel ?
Ce sont des institutions
socioculturelles
sous influence wokiste ?
C'est la communication
qui est omniprésente partout ?
C'est la tyrannie des opinions ?
Et face à cela,
un pouvoir politique qui est gelé ?
-Je crois qu'il faut en revenir,
- on l'a déjà mis en valeur -
à l'ambiguïté de cette notion
d'autorité
qui avait été bien éclairée
par Hannah Arendt.
Parce que quand on parle de crise
de l'autorité, spontanément,
on pense à l'insuffisance
de l'ordre public
ou à l'insuffisance
de la contrainte,
ou du contrôle.
L'autorité, normalement,
c'est une obéissance consentie.
Cela renvoie à des valeurs,
chez nous,
aux valeurs de la République.
-Vous distinguez autorité
et autoritarisme.
-En face, on a deux notions
contraires à l'autorité.
Il y a la violence
et l'autoritarisme.
Il peut aujourd'hui
prendre la forme,
soit d'extrémisme à l'intérieur
des démocraties,
soit de régime autoritaire,
d'empire autoritaire,
dont on voit qu'aujourd'hui,
ils ont de nouveau
une agressivité extrême
contre la démocratie.
Alors, qu'est ce qui s'est passé ?
Dans l'ensemble
du monde démocratique,
les démocraties ont fait une erreur
après l'effondrement
de l'Union soviétique,
on a pensé que c'était la victoire
de la démocratie,
de l'économie de marché,
les illusions
de la fin
de l'histoire, et derrière,
il y a une série de chocs,
qui ont déstabilisé profondément
les nations libres.
Il y a eu 2001,
les guerres enlisées perdues
de l'Afghanistan
jusqu'au Sahel, le krach de 2008,
la crise de l'euro, les pandémies.
Tout ça, partout,
on voit que ça a déstabilisé
la classe moyenne et ça crée
un énorme désordre.
Il suffit
de voir aux Etats-Unis.
Normalement, aux Etats-Unis,
le fondement de l'autorité,
c'est qu'on croit à la Constitution
et on croit au vote.
-Oui, mais en face, vous trouvez
que le pouvoir politique
fait son boulot ?
-Aux Etats-Unis,
on seulement le pouvoir politique
ne fait pas son travail,
mais Donald Trump
est un agent de destruction massive
de ce qui a été l'ordre
et l'autorité politique
aux Etats-Unis.
Aux Etats-Unis, l'autorité,
c'est la Constitution.
A partir du moment
où on a un président qui a été élu,
maintenant un candidat qui,
de manière frontale,
remet en cause
la Constitution et le vote,
là, en l'occurrence,
c'est une force politique
qui participe
de la déstabilisation.
On a ça partout.
En France,
la situation reste une situation
exceptionnelle, pour les raisons
qui ont été décrites,
parce que la France
est particulièrement vulnérable.
Quand on voit les hauts et les bas
depuis 1789,
comme la révolution
a mis en face
l'Etat et le citoyen,
il y a pas de société civile
entre les deux.
Quand l'Etat est bien géré
et voit que le citoyen est prospère,
le système fonctionne bien.
Quand on commence à avoir
des chocs et que l'Etat devient
obèse et impuissant d'un côté,
que le citoyen
est totalement désorienté, là,
ça dysfonctionne.
On a bien ce problème,
ce double problème
de l'efficacité.
Un Etat obèse et impuissant,
il récupère 58 % du PIB
mais il n'est plus capable
de produire ni de la santé,
ni de l'éducation,
ni de la police,
ni de la justice, ni des transports
dans des conditions
d'efficacité correcte
pour la population.
Il y a derrière le problème
des valeurs.
Ce que vous avez rappelé...
On peut rajouter un épisode
que vous avez directement connu,
qui est évidemment gravissime,
les attentats de 2015,
le fait qu'on a une partie
de la population
qui vit sur le territoire
et une partie des Français
qui ne se reconnaissent plus
dans les lois la République,
ensuite, on a eu
les gilets jaunes,
les manifestations
contre les retraites,
les émeutes urbaines.
On voit très bien qu'aujourd'hui,
j'allais dire,
chacun fait sa loi.
Pour les uns,
c'est la loi religieuse,
pour les autres, c'est la loi
des gangs et des bandes,
pour les troisièmes,
c'est la loi des communautés,
mais de fait,
c'est la vraie crise de l'autorité.
Cela ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'y a pas d'autorité,
mais l'autorité,
ça peut être l'imam,
l'autorité,
ça peut être le chef de gang,
Ce n'est plus une autorité.
C'est une autorité
collective et reconnue.
-Sur cette autorité déconstruite,
avec une violence qui est là
quasiment permanente,
Manuel Valls,
qu'est-ce que vous pensez ?
Jean-Pierre Le Goff, un sociologue,
dans un essai récent,
"Mes années folles",
à propos de mai 68,
met en cause le gauchisme culturel
en disant
qu'il est essentiellement
violent et nihiliste.
Est-ce qu'on peut faire
une comparaison
entre cette violence-là
et la violence qu'il y a eu
en France ces derniers temps
dans les banlieues
et dans les métropoles ?
Parce que ça s'est exprimé
avec de la violence.
-Oui, mais il y a des éléments
que nous partageons
avec les grandes démocraties
occidentales,
le monde libre,
avec qui nous partageons
des valeurs communes,
et nous avons subi
les uns et les autres
à peu près les mêmes chocs,
les effets de la globalisation
économique pour aller vite,
et qui s'accentuent
avec le rôle et le pouvoir
des GAFAM,
le sentiment, au fond,
pour les citoyens,
qu'on perd le pouvoir démocratique
qui s'exerce
dans chaque nation.
Il y a des éléments
de perte d'autorité que là aussi,
on retrouve un peu partout.
Je fais vite,
mais l'autorité du parent,
des parents,
l'autorité du professeur.
Peut-être que cela vient
de mouvements
de fond de la société,
qu'on peut imputer,
même s'il y a eu aussi
des effets positifs,
de mai 68.
Mais chez nous,
cette crise de l'autorité
est profondément liée,
pas seulement,
et c'est une différence
avec d'autres pays,
où l'Etat est peu présent,
avec une crise de l'Etat
et de son efficacité.
Et je ne refais pas la liste,
ou je la refais, qui a été rappelée
il y a un instant :
santé, école,
police, énergie, transports.
Les Français ont le sentiment que,
pour être trivial,
tout fout le camp.
Le lien de l'autorité politique
est à faire avec la crise
de l'autorité de l'Etat.
Si vous rajoutez à cela,
d'ailleurs,
- parce que vous m'interrogiez
sur le président actuel -
avec des contradictions,
mais on remet en cause
l'ENA, on remet en cause
le rôle des préfets...
-L'ensemble des corps constitués.
-...le corps diplomatique,
donc les corps constitués,
même si à l'intérieur,
ça ne change pas forcément beaucoup,
le message qui passe
est qu'on continue
à effriter cette autorité
de l'Etat.
Moi, je pense que le rôle
du politique,
il est de ne pas
se laisser entraîner.
C'est facile à dire,
surtout quand on n'est plus
au pouvoir.
J'ai le sentiment, parfois,
que le pouvoir m'échappait,
et dans d'autres occasions,
par le verbe,
par l'action,
notamment face
aux attentats terroristes,
on pouvait évidemment agir.
Souvent, le politique arrive à agir
en temps de crise.
C'est là où, d'une certaine manière,
il a la réponse à court terme,
mais sur le moyen
et surtout sur le long terme,
c'est là où il est en crise.
-Anne Lauvergeon ?
-Je voudrais rebondir,
parce que je crois qu'un défaut
du politique aujourd'hui
est de ne pas savoir anticiper
les crises.
Je prends un sujet
que je connais un petit peu :
l'énergie.
J'ai sonné le tocsin un peu partout.
En septembre 2021,
il était parfaitement clair
qu'on allait
devant une crise énergétique
grave pour l'hiver.
Que n'ai-je entendu ?
A tout niveau de l'Etat,
que ce soit
dans les administrations,
ou dans le monde politique.
C'était vraiment une vision
catastrophiste, etc.
-Il y avait une pression des Verts
contre le nucléaire.
-Je ne parlais pas de cela.
On va vers une crise énergétique.
Il faut faire comme
les Espagnols et les Portugais
dans un mécanisme très malin
qui leur a permis
de faire des économies
et de protéger les citoyens.
Faire comme les Espagnols
et les Portugais,
ce n'est pas digne des Français.
Non, c'était :
"Je n'entends rien
"avant d'être devant le sujet."
Ce qui me frappe
dans cet effritement,
c'est la perte des sachants.
Je reprends l'énergie,
je peux reprendre d'autres sujets,
il y avait,
dans le système étatique,
des sachants.
Il y a 30 ans,
Jean Syrota, directeur général
de l'énergie
des matières premières,
je peux vous assurer qu'il avait
une batterie de gens,
qu'il avait des opinions différentes
de celles d'EDF,
ou d'autres,
mais il y avait des corpus
et un suivi.
-Vous diriez la même chose
du fait
que les prix Nobel
de ces deux dernières années,
français,
travaillent
à l'étranger ?
-C'est aussi le ridicule
d'indiquer une date de retraite
pour tout le monde,
quelles que soient les conditions,
et en particulier à 60 ans.
C'est absurde.
C'est l'idée qu'après
un certain âge,
on n'est plus productif,
donc on peut vous jeter.
Je vais vous dire à quel point
sur des sujets essentiels,
qui sont vraiment des sujets
de l'Etat-nation,
on a laissé abandonner...
Je vous donne un exemple
très concret...
-Est-ce que vous diriez
que les politiques sont émasculés
du haut savoir,
des grands savoirs ?
-Dans un certain nombre de cas,
il y a une organisation
qui s'est mise en place,
qui leur enlève
la possibilité de savoir
suffisamment tôt pour prévenir.
Je vous donne
un exemple très concret,
lié à l'énergie.
Pendant des dizaines d'années,
vous citiez le général
de Gaulle,
mais ça existait bien avant lui,
des services
du ministère de l'Industrie
prévoyaient les consommations
énergétiques de la France
à long terme et qui essayaient
de voir si la demande
et l'offre
pourraient se rencontrer.
Aujourd'hui,
ça n'est plus l'Etat qui le fait.
C'est une filiale d'EDF.
L'Etat n'a plus de position
sur un sujet aussi majeur.
C'est RTE qui fait ça.
En 2021,
ils sortent des prévisions
entièrement différentes
de celles de 2023.
Dans un cas, il fallait réduire
la production et la consommation...
-Julien Aubert
veut dire un mot là-dessus ?
-C'est peut-être le fait
que RTE soit dirigé
par un ancien conseiller
du président de la République
qui explique cela.
Je suis d'accord avec le fait
qu'il y a la perte des sachants,
la perte d'expertise.
Dans une crise d'autorité,
il y a deux volets :
il y a une crise de l'Etat,
de son mode d'organisation,
le fait d'assumer la responsabilité
et d'être capable
d'avoir une vision prospective,
et il y a une crise de société,
en face.
On a fait une expérience
grandeur nature
avec les réseaux sociaux.
Je crois que l'humain,
qui est à la fois citoyen
avec un certain nombre de règles
et qui, la moitié du temps,
est sur un espace numérique
parfaitement horizontal,
où il n'y a pas de règles,
d'obligations,
pas de responsabilité,
pas d'individualisation,
et où c'est un peu
une loi de la jungle,
ça rétroagit sur la société.
-Julien Aubert,
je voudrais vous poser
une question très personnelle.
Vous êtes un politique
qui vient du sud,
parce que vous êtes un élu
du Vaucluse.
Comment vous expliquez
cette contradiction
de l'électorat,
qui est plus tenté par voter
pour des hommes farouchement
ou des femmes farouchement engagées,
comme Marine Le Pen
ou Jean-Luc Mélenchon,
plutôt que pour des politiques
qui sont modérés
mais qui sont en même temps
rigoureux
dans leur gestion de la société ?
Vous, appartenant au mouvement
Les Républicains,
et même sur vos terres
vauclusiennes,
vous aviez des positions
affirmées.
Or vous avez été battu
par plus extrême.
Comment expliquez-vous
cette contradiction ?
-J'ai été battu par quelqu'un
de la majorité,
pas par plus extrême.
-Il y a eu, à côté...
-Il y a eu une vague.
D'abord,
il y a des phénomènes de vagues
et d'étiquettes,
avec une colère populaire,
et un divorce,
étant donné qu'il y a eu
des crises démocratiques, avant,
il y a eu des séismes démocratiques.
Ce qui s'est passé en 2005
avec un référendum européen,
où les Français ont voté
à 55 % contre un traité,
et ensuite,
les élus ont détricoté,
n'a pas enclenché
un mécanisme de confiance
de la part des gens
qui avaient voté non.
D'ailleurs,
ces gens qui avaient voté non,
quand vous prenez la sociologie,
c'était plutôt des gens issus
des classes populaires,
les classes les moins riches.
Vous retrouvez ensuite, par exemple,
ce qu'il s'est passé aux élections
présidentielles
avec le front républicain.
Les électeurs
de Marine Le Pen
sont plutôt des électeurs
venant des classes populaires.
Il y a le sentiment
d'une dépossession
de dire :
"Les élus ont fait cause commune
"pour m'empêcher de gagner,
"m'empêcher d'exprimer
la souffrance qu'est la mienne."
Un sondage très intéressant
montrait que 80 % des électeurs
de Marine Le Pen
considéraient qu'ils n'étaient pas
heureux dans la vie qu'ils menaient
ou qu'il leur manquait des choses.
A mon avis, on a utilisé
parfois la démocratie
contre la démocratie,
ça n'aide pas à comprendre
la manière dont ça fonctionne.
Deuxièmement,
le sentiment que les décisions
sont prises par d'autres,
et qu'on a faussé le jeu
démocratique pour les empêcher
de faire entendre
leurs revendications.
Tout ça se focalise
sur des partis protestataires,
qui deviennent des partis
d'identification de victimisation,
en disant :
"Je suis mal dans mon système
"et je vote pour le parti
"qui est mis à l'écart."
-Vous venez de voir la citation
d'Henry Kissinger.
Nicolas Baverez,
est-ce que nos hommes politiques
manquent-ils de caractère ?
Est-ce que c'est lié,
ce manque de caractère,
à une méconnaissance de l'histoire ?
Il me souvient qu'Henry Kissinger
disait d'Obama
qu'il n'avait pas
ce recul de l'histoire.
-C'est Raymond Aron
qui avait critiqué,
justement, Valéry Giscard d'Estaing,
en lui disant qu'il n'avait pas
le sens du tragique de l'histoire,
quand il était allé discuter
avec Brejnev,
exactement au lendemain
de l'invasion de l'Afghanistan.
En fait, le tragique de l'histoire,
d'une certaine manière,
on est plus que servis.
Je crois qu'il faut rappeler
la difficulté
de ce qu'est
de gouverner aujourd'hui.
Quand on regarde le nombre de chocs,
on a une crise sanitaire
qui se poursuit,
on a une crise énergétique,
on a une crise alimentaire,
on a l'inflation qui redémarre
et une crise monétaire,
On a une crise stratégique
et une crise climatique.
Evidemment...
-Le caractère,
c'est le contraire
de la versatilité.
-Là-dedans,
il faut effectivement essayer
de tracer un chemin.
C'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui,
ce qui frappe quand même,
c'est qu'il y en a qui y arrivent,
quand même, ou qui le dessinent.
Je prends l'exemple
des Etats-Unis.
Aujourd'hui, la société est en état
de quasi guerre civile,
mais ils ont inventé l'IRA,
donc cette machine à subventionner.
Derrière,
il y a une vraie ligne stratégique :
"Je réindustrialise,
je fais la transition climatique,
"et je me sers de tout ça
"pour restabiliser
la classe moyenne."
On verra si ça va fonctionner,
mais il y a une idée.
A l'extérieur, l'idée,
c'est que maintenant,
la rivalité
est avec la Chine
et qu'on va utiliser la technologie
pour dissuader la Chine
et garder l'avantage militaire.
Quand on prend l'Europe du nord,
il y a quand même des endroits
en Europe
avec démocraties
qui ne vont pas si mal.
Quand on regarde la Suède,
la stratégie zéro fossiles,
la Norvège, ces pays ont réussi,
avec des tensions fortes,
y compris
sur le plan migratoire,
mais ont commencé à trouver
des formules où le citoyen
se sent engagé
dans un projet national,
on a de la compétitivité,
on a de la transition,
et on a une certaine forme
de stabilité politique
et une capacité à remettre en cause
beaucoup de choses,
puisque la Suède
intègre l'OTAN.
Pour le coup, ce sont
des siècles de neutralité
qui sont remis en question.
Ce qui manque aujourd'hui,
en revanche, effectivement,
dans un pays comme la France,
c'est la fameuse...
Je pense que c'est la meilleure
formule qui ait été utilisée,
celle de Fourquet,
sur l'archipel français.
Cette archipélisation du pays,
elle vaut pour la société,
l'économie.
-Elle vaut
pour les sociétés démocratiques.
-Oui, mais il y en a, vous voyez,
qui ont commencé à essayer
de reconstruire
ou d'essayer de retisser des fils.
C'est vrai que,
comme il a été dit,
sur les deux bouts du système,
puisque chez nous,
il y a peu de sociétés civiles,
l'Etat, aujourd'hui,
il est surendetté,
et puis il y a
une extrême confusion.
Regardez ce dont on a parlé.
On parle d'éducation.
Ensuite, on peut penser
ce qu'on veut,
mais le même président
de la République
ne peut pas avoir
comme même ministre
M. Blanquer et M. Ndiaye.
Le nucléaire,
on peut pas expliquer
qu'on ferme Fessenheim
et redécouvrir
que finalement,
on arrête de fermer,
parce que finalement...
Vous voyez,
quand on regarde l'essentiel,
on peut pas discuter
pendant six mois avec Poutine
pour dire qu'on est
avec les Ukrainiens
et qu'on va accélérer
leur entrée dans l'UE.
Il n'y a pas un thème...
Parce que chez nous,
l'impulsion du haut
est importante.
Il n'y a pas un thème sur lequel
le président de la République
n'a pas dit tout et son contraire.
Cela n'est pas tout...
-Nicolas Baverez dit
ce que disent les Chinois :
"Le poisson pourrit par la tête."
-J'y ai vu plutôt une critique
du "En même temps".
-Exactement.
-C'est un slogan électoral génial,
mais ça ne permet ni de présider,
ni de gouverner.
Il y a l'autre dimension,
qui est l'anomie
de pan entier du territoire
et de la population,
et ça, c'est 40 ans de déclin
économique et social,
mais aujourd'hui, ça prend
une dimension pathologique.
-Vous vouliez dire un mot.
-Je pense que ce que chacun dit,
et en France,
on le voit peut-être davantage,
c'est cette contradiction,
ce choc entre la verticalité,
y compris incarnée
par nos institutions,
par l'attente du rôle de l'Etat,
et l'horizontalité de nos sociétés,
accélérée par les réseaux sociaux
et que dire demain
de l'intelligence artificielle.
Il y a un paradoxe,
car ça frappe toutes les sociétés,
cela ne produit pas forcément plus
de démocratie
mais peut-être plus de confusion,
et peut amener à l'autoritarisme.
C'était le cas de Trump,
ou comme Milei en Argentine,
où sur la base
de la désinformation
véhiculée
par ces réseaux sociaux,
on va vers des candidatures
ou des élections
de personnages
très antidémocratiques,
très illibéraux,
en tout cas,
qui remettent en cause les systèmes.
On peut décrire à foison
les sociétés
dans lesquelles nous sommes,
et je partage les analyses
qui ont été apportées jusqu'ici.
Quelles sont les solutions ?
Je crois beaucoup à la stratégie
à long terme.
Je vais prendre un exemple
où le pouvoir politique, acculé,
a été obligé
de faire un virage sur l'aile
massif,
c'est l'Allemagne,
qui, en quelques mois,
a été obligée de changer
de stratégie
énergétique,
- la dépendance
au gaz et au pétrole russe -
et d'avoir
une autre vision stratégique
dans son rapport militaire,
avec sa propre histoire.
Ce qui se passe est considérable.
Ils vont réussir,
avec du temps, avec difficulté.
Ils n'ont pas les mêmes
problèmes financiers
que les nôtres,
donc ils auront
des marges de manoeuvre,
mais c'est un changement.
Si je veux rester optimiste,
ce changement stratégique
est imposé aux Français
et aux Européens.
Au fond, la crise pandémique,
la crise énergétique
et la crise stratégique,
la guerre en Ukraine,
nous obligent nous, Français
et Européens à changer.
Et là, cela nous oblige à des choix
qui sont massifs,
en matière de dépenses militaires,
en matière d'autonomie
ou d'indépendance énergétique
et industrielle.
Les investissements massifs
qu'il faut faire
en termes de semi-conducteurs
ou de batteries
nous obligent au changement
mais il faut l'expliquer.
C'est peut-être ça,
la crise de l'âme.
Ce qu'on peut reprocher
au pouvoir actuel,
mais peut-être aussi
aux pouvoirs passés,
c'est de ne pas indiquer
le cap stratégique,
c'est de ne pas dire où nous allons.
-Comment on peut...
-Le poids de la guerre en Ukraine,
c'est un sujet
de réflexion et d'action.
Je ne comprends pas
qu'on n'y revienne pas sans cesse.
Nous allons vivre avec,
avec des conséquences
très importantes.
La parole, de ce point de vue-là,
du président de la République,
devrait se concentrer
sur l'essentiel,
et non pas être dispersée
en permanence,
entre des annonces
sur le plan énergétique,
ou sur des brigades de gendarmerie.
Ce sont des sujets importants,
mais la parole présidentielle
et donc politique
devrait se concentrer
sur les trois-quatre sujets
essentiels
qui font de notre avenir
et de notre histoire.
-J'aimerais bien
que vous nous disiez,
Anne Lauvergeon,
si cette contradiction,
qui vient d'être évoquée,
sur les choix essentiels
du pays,
disons ces 20 dernières années,
on a dit une chose et son contraire.
Comment voulez-vous
que les gens adhèrent ?
-Je dirais
plusieurs choses.
Le "En même temps"
est une idée assez séduisante,
parce qu'on est tous
un peu ambivalents,
on veut une chose
et on en veut une autre.
-Il y a ambiguïté
et ambivalence.
-Voilà, ambiguïté et ambivalence,
ça flatte.
Le sujet,
c'est qu'on est face
à un certain nombre de problèmes
qui doivent être pris
avec énormément de rationalité.
On a passé les 20 dernières années
à dire que l'industrie,
c'était quelque chose de sale,
d'inintéressant,
qu'il suffisait de concevoir,
qu'on était plus intelligents,
pour faire du marketing,
on est tellement meilleurs,
et puis on irait,
en délocalisant, très loin,
qu'importent les emplois
et le reste.
On se réveille groggy,
et on dit :
"Ah bah tiens,
il faudrait réindustrialiser."
Je pense qu'il y a
une forme de consensus
sur la réindustrialisation.
-Après y avoir eu un consensus
anti-industrie.
-Et après avoir
suivi l'Allemagne
sur tous ses errements énergétiques.
Il y a une culpabilité générale.
Mais sur la réindustrialisation,
elle suppose
une chose très simple,
deux choses très simples.
C'est d'avoir de l'énergie
pas chère, compétitive.
Or vous prenez la Suède,
vous prenez la Finlande,
ils sont aujourd'hui
à 15 euros le mégawattheure.
On est à combien aujourd'hui,
ici, en France ?
Plus de 90.
Or...
il fait beau,
il y a aucune raison qu'on soit
à ce prix-là, et les features
pour cet hiver sont monstrueux.
Donc il n'y a pas
de compétitivité de l'Etat français
pour une réindustrialisation.
Le premier sujet,
c'est comment on va retrouver
une énergie pas chère.
On ne s'y attaque pas.
Deuxième sujet :
pour faire de l'industrie,
il faut des matières premières.
La Palice aurait pu le dire.
Où sont les matières premières ?
Où sont nos groupes miniers ?
Où sont nos capacités
à sourcer ces matières premières ?
On n'a jamais autant parlé
de méga-usines de batteries.
On va les remplir
avec quoi ?
Les métaux rares,
ils viennent d'où ?
Donc on est...
On se nourrit de mots,
on se nourrit de mots,
on est très heureux,
on dit réindustrialisation,
fantastique,
et il y a rien derrière.
Le travail en amont
que font formidablement bien
les pays nordiques
et d'autres endroits
dans le monde...
L'IRA, c'est ça aussi,
aux Etats-Unis.
C'est réfléchir
à l'essentiel, c'est-à-dire
dire : "On veut pallier
"le changement climatique,
"on veut la réindustrialisation,
on veut
"des emplois en France.
"Comment va-t-on y arriver
dans un monde compétitif ?
Eh bien ça, ça suppose
des technologies,
de l'innovation...
-Et des ressources humaines.
-On vous a écoutée,
Anne Lauvergeon.
Julien Aubert,
par rapport
à ce qui vient d'être dit là,
à votre avis, d'où vient
cette versatilité politique
qui empêche de faire
des choix clairs,
de changer tous les 10 ans
de politique ?
Est-ce que c'est
un manque de caractère ?
parce que ces politiques
ne connaissent pas l'histoire ?
Ils déclassent
les corps constitués, etc.
A quoi vous attribuez ce...
-D'abord, il y a
une part d'idéologie.
-Donc il y a une idéologie oiseuse
qui consiste à...
-Lorsqu'on décide
de changer l'ENA,
lorsqu'on décide
de décréter que les diplomates
ne doivent plus
être un corps à part,
lorsqu'on décide d'ouvrir
les postes de préfet
pour en faire une espèce
de marché libre,
avec la possibilité
d'aller et de venir, tout cela
procède pour moi d'une idéologie.
C'est pas la mienne,
parce que je pense
que l'Etat, ça se pense.
Ca se pense par des gens
qui aiment l'Etat
et qui savent
pourquoi l'Etat est là.
Moi, je ne me pique pas
en tant que fonctionnaire
de réfléchir à la manière dont
une entreprise doit fonctionner.
Je ne suis pas légitime.
Ca veut pas dire
que j'ai pas mon point de vue.
Je peux avoir
un point de vue externe.
L'Etat ne peut pas fonctionner
comme une entreprise.
C'est trop important
pour qu'on le pense comme tel.
Premièrement,
on ne pense pas l'Etat,
on ne pense plus l'Etat.
Donc il y a une part d'idéologie.
Deuxièmement, il y a
un manque de conviction.
A un moment donné,
ce n'est pas qu'une affaire
d'intuition, la politique.
C'est aussi arbitrer...
On ne demande pas à un politique
d'être omniscient,
mais on lui demande quand même
d'être suffisamment informé,
de peser le pour et le contre
et de trancher des choix
en ayant une stratégie.
Ca supposerait de rebâtir des outils
pour penser temporellement
et géographiquement.
On ne voit pas la mondialisation
de la même manière
à Toulouse, où on a Airbus,
et en Vaucluse,
où l'agriculture a été laminée
par l'ouverture aux marchés
espagnol et marocain.
Et puis enfin,
il y a effectivement
la difficulté
qu'on a tous pointée,
qui est qu'on a une partie
de la population qui ne vote plus,
qui ne consent plus,
qui est protestataire,
d'où la tentation
d'essayer de regrouper
ceux qui restent,
et le "en même temps"
est aussi
une tentative de créer
une espèce de tiers qui pourrait
permettre d'équilibrer le navire.
On peut être d'accord
sur certains points,
mais à un moment donné,
on doit trancher.
Ca a été la grande faiblesse
du président actuel.
On pourrait dire
de manière positive
qu'on a tous un jour été d'accord
avec Emmanuel Macron
ou qu'on le sera tous...
-Très sincèrement,
Julien Aubert,
est-ce que vous pensez
que Jacques Chirac
tranchait plus
qu'Emmanuel Macron ?
-Je pense qu'il...
Je l'ai un peu moins connu.
-De ce que vous savez
de cette histoire.
-Je pense qu'il a pris parfois
des positions très structurantes,
en petit nombre.
Après, c'est pas le président qui,
pour moi, a permis d'accélérer
l'entrée de la France
dans l'histoire
ou sa réintroduction.
C'est pas mon modèle à moi
de présidence...
-Sarkozy,
c'est plus votre modèle ?
-Au moins, Nicolas Sarkozy
a tenté de faire des choses.
Certes, il a déçu
à certains moments,
mais dans la crise,
il a pris en main le pays,
et je pense qu'il a évité
pendant la crise financière
que ça s'aggrave.
Il a tenté d'impulser
une volonté politique.
Ce qui est grave, c'est quand
vous avez une forme de tentative
de "on ne touche rien, on met
des rustines pour que ça tienne
"encore un peu".
Mais au bout d'un moment,
la machine perd des boulons,
et le coût final
de la réparation
chez le garagiste...
-D'accord, mais sur le nucléaire,
Emmanuel Macron
a pris la bonne décision.
-Il a fini par la prendre.
-Les prédécesseurs
n'avaient pas fait mieux.
-Ah non. Sur les prédécesseurs,
il y a eu
la fermeture de Superphénix
qui était une erreur,
mais rien n'incitait
M. Macron à fermer
le programme Astrid
de quatrième génération,
rien ne l'obligeait
à continuer la faute
qui avait été faite
sur Fessenheim,
ni à annoncer la fermeture
de différentes centrales nucléaires
sans avoir vérifié si on avait
les moyens de compenser.
Tout cela, on l'avait annoncé
dès le quinquennat d'avant.
Donc il a fini in extremis
par faire un tête-à-queue.
Reste que, si aujourd'hui
la filière est dans cet état,
il a une part de responsabilité,
pas la totalité.
-Nicolas Baverez,
vous voulez
dire quelque chose ?
-Sur le diagnostic, on est
à peu près tous d'accord.
Le pouvoir actuel,
il est mû par trois choses :
la peur,
depuis les gilets jaunes,
et on le voit avec la poursuite
de ce que vous appelez
les dépenses qui sont faites
pour essayer de colmater
dès qu'on a une protestation,
l'impuissance,
parce que les mots
n'ont plus de prise
sur les choses,
et puis,
le troisième point,
c'est effectivement
la rupture avec la connaissance,
ça a été dit, avec la science.
Ca s'est vu pendant la pandémie
de manière incroyable,
et on compense ça en faisant
des Conseils de défense sanitaire
qui n'ont aucun sens.
On a mimé
le Conseil de défense,
et on applique
le Conseil de défense
à l'écologie,
au sanitaire.
Voilà le diagnostic.
La vraie bonne question,
c'est celle
que posait Manuel Valls :
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
-Justement.
-Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?
Il me semble que d'abord...
-Ca mériterait
une deuxième émission.
-Pour aller vite...
-Oui, il nous reste
très peu de temps.
-On parle de réforme
des institutions
et de référendums.
La Ve République
a quand même été faite
pour gérer les crises,
mais avec un système militaire :
la stratégie est à l'Elysée,
l'opératif est à Matignon,
le tactique est
dans les ministères.
On a tout fait
remonter à l'Elysée,
ça peut pas marcher.
Si on veut aussi
pouvoir associer les citoyens,
il faut retrouver l'esprit
de la Ve République
et remettre
des contre-pouvoirs,
parce que si on ne discute pas
des choses, si ça vient toujours
du haut, ça ne marche pas.
-Enfin, la Ve République,
c'était aussi
une monarchie républicaine.
Tout était en haut,
quand même.
-Tout n'était pas en haut.
Quand on regarde
les premiers ministres
du général de Gaulle,
ils ont eu des vraies marges
de manoeuvre.
Je rappelle que le nucléaire,
c'est beaucoup
Pierre Messmer,
qui n'était pas président
de la République. Les ministres
du général de Gaulle
avaient une vraie marge
de manoeuvre.
C'est pas le général de Gaulle
qui nommait à tous les emplois...
-Soyez bref, parce qu'on a
très peu de temps.
-Il faut qu'on se concentre
sur quelques priorités :
la production,
donc la réindustrialisation,
l'énergie,
l'éducation, la sécurité.
Et pour les citoyens,
c'est ça qui me paraît
très important,
on l'a dit, l'autorité,
c'est une obéissance
qui est consentie,
donc si on veut
que les gens croient
à la liberté, il faut
qu'ils aient été éduqués
à la liberté
et qu'ils en comprennent
les responsabilités.
-Est-ce que c'est faisable
dans une société pluriculturelle ?
-Bien sûr, c'est faisable.
Quand on prend
l'Europe du Nord,
là encore,
ils y arrivent.
-Je suis d'accord
avec l'ensemble des priorités
qu'il faut développer...
-Et la vôtre,
comme choc de rupture ?
-L'immigration.
C'est peut-être
un des derniers champs
sur lequel les Français
espèrent...
-Manuel Valls, une précision.
Vous êtes pour, par exemple,
la politique danoise de suppression
de l'attractivité à l'immigration ?
-Plutôt. Plutôt.
Plutôt, même si
c'est évidemment...
Je suis pour un message clair
qui est de dire stop
à une forme d'immigration.
On remet tout le chantier
sur la table et on fait
participer les Français
à cette décision.
Ca a des conséquences
constitutionnelles
et politiques,
mais c'est un des champs
qui touche à peu près
toutes les difficultés...
-Au Danemark,
on a bien les deux :
on a le contrôle des flux
et l'intégration.
-C'est à la fois dire non,
repenser notre politique
d'immigration, mais aussi
repenser la question de l'esprit :
qu'est-ce que c'est, être français ?
C'est la question
de l'assimilation,
pour répondre
à l'une des crises
qu'on a évoquées.
C'est un des derniers éléments
sur lequel les Français se disent
qu'il y a des bases d'un accord
majoritaire dans notre pays,
à condition qu'on le veuille bien.
C'est un des rendez-vous majeurs
qui démontrerait
que l'action politique
est encore possible.
Le deuxième élément,
c'est le choix stratégique.
Un des éléments qui montrent
que le politique est utile...
-C'est quoi,
le choix stratégique ?
-Volodymyr Zelensky,
à un moment précis,
par le verbe
et par la manière d'être,
a remobilisé son peuple.
Nous ne sommes pas en guerre,
mais cela veut bien dire
que ce qui se passe en Ukraine
et avec la Russie
est pour nous fondamental.
-Choc de rupture,
Julien Aubert,
sur l'immigration, sur l'Ukraine.
Vous nous direz ce que vous pensez
de la position de M. Sarkozy
sur l'Ukraine.
-Je trouve que
Nicolas Sarkozy a eu raison
de s'exprimer sur...
J'étais de son avis.
Ca faisait très longtemps
que j'avais pas été de son avis,
mais je pense qu'il a
une vision lucide et réaliste
de la manière dont on doit aborder
le conflit ukrainien.
-Ca veut dire qu'on laisse
une Russie impériale ?
-Non.
On comprend qu'il y ait
un rapport de force
et on comprend que la priorité est
de mettre un terme à ce conflit...
-Tout le monde le souhaite.
-...on ne le fera pas
en ne prenant qu'un seul camp.
On n'est pas dans le monde
dans lequel
on devrait être,
mais dans lequel on est.
Il faut mettre fin
au fédéralisme européen
et aux lubies
du couple franco-allemand
et de Mme Von der Leyen,
revoir la décentralisation,
qui a complètement
déresponsabilisé
les élus locaux,
remettre
de la responsabilité politique,
ça va du président de la République
jusqu'aux maires,
mais il faut restaurer
le pouvoir des maires,
de manière à ce que,
à un moment donné,
on remette la maison d'aplomb.
-J'imagine que vous êtes d'accord
sur l'immigration
avec Manuel Valls.
-Et sur l'école.
-Anne Lauvergeon,
votre choc de rupture pour avancer ?
-Expliciter
un petit nombre de sujets,
parce qu'il faut hiérarchiser
les problèmes,
or, là, on est
dans la dispersion la plus totale,
un petit nombre de sujets
dont on a parlé ce soir.
Après cette hiérarchisation,
discuter de plans de long terme,
retrouver le temps long
et faire que ceux-ci soient adoptés
de manière collective
pour qu'on puisse...
-Un ministre du Plan ?
-Un ministre du Plan
n'a aucun pouvoir.
Tout ça doit venir...
-C'est une bonne idée.
-Les ministres du Plan
n'ont plus de pouvoir
depuis longtemps.
Il faut retrouver
le sens du temps long
et le sens de la stratégie.
Il faut qu'on joue nos cartes,
et on les joue pas bien
en ce moment,
parce qu'on est brouillon,
parce qu'on change d'avis,
parce qu'on n'a pas
le sens de la stratégie.
Donc retrouvons-la,
et regardons
ce qui se passe ailleurs.
Arrêtons de penser
qu'on est les seuls
à inventer tout.
-Merci beaucoup.
Le temps écoulé est là.
Il me reste à vous présenter
une brève bibliographie.
Manuel Valls,
vous avez publié
"Le courage
guidait leurs pas :
"12 destins
face à l'Histoire".
En deux mots,
ces 12 destins,
c'est quoi,
les deux mots
qui les caractérisent ?
-La liberté, d'abord,
et le fait
de ne jamais suivre la meute.
Au fond, chacun,
un homme, une femme,
peut changer le destin
d'une communauté,
d'un peuple et du monde.
-C'est effectivement ça,
la liberté,
comme vous le dites.
Bérénice Levet,
"Le courage de la dissidence",
aux Editions
de l'Observatoire.
C'est un livre
qui met l'accent justement
sur la dissidence
quand on n'est pas d'accord
pour, j'allais dire,
aboyer avec la meute.
Nicolas Baverez,
"Démocraties
contre empires autoritaires".
On y est, là.
Qui est gagnant,
qui est perdant ?
-Ce qui est intéressant,
c'est que cette année 2022
a été effectivement
tragique, sanglante,
mais qu'on a vu
que du côté de la Chine,
en fait, la Chine
n'est pas infaillible.
On l'a vu avec la Covid
et aujourd'hui
l'économie qui va mal.
On a vu que la Russie
n'est pas invincible.
On a vu que les démocraties,
ça rejoint notre thème,
pouvaient quand même
bouger, réagir,
même si, aujourd'hui, l'issue
de cette grande confrontation
est loin d'être jouée.
Le livre s'achève
par une citation
de Raymond Aron,
qui peut peut-être
résumer notre conversation.
Elle date de juin 39
et il disait :
"Je crois
"à la victoire finale
des démocraties,
"mais à une condition,
qu'elles le veuillent."
-C'est du "en même temps".
-Non, pour le coup,
c'est à mon avis un choix
tranché
dans une période tragique :
le primat de la liberté
et le primat de l'engagement
et du combat.
Aujourd'hui, on est
de nouveau,
à l'intérieur de nos nations
comme dans l'ordre
international,
dans un de ces moments
où le choix cardinal, c'est celui
de la défense de la liberté.
-Anne Lauvergeon,
vous n'avez pas
publié de livre
pour cette émission,
mais vous en préparez un
sur Mitterrand,
qui va sortir bientôt.
Est-ce qu'il avait
du caractère ?
Est-ce que vous allez
en parler ?
-Très peu de caractère,
François Mitterrand.
Oui, je lui ai fait
une promesse.
Un soir de juin 1994,
il m'a demandé d'écrire
sur ce que j'avais vu,
et je lui ai dit non,
tout le monde va faire
"Mitterrand et moi",
d'ailleurs "Moi et Mitterrand",
dans l'ordre qui va bien.
"Je ne me livrerai pas à ça."
Il m'a dit : "Mais si !
"Mais vous le ferez pas
tout de suite.
"Faites-le dans 20 ans."
Eh bien voilà, je le fais.
Ca s'appelle "La promesse",
puisque j'ai fait
cette promesse.
-C'est un joli titre.
-Je vais raconter Mitterrand,
ce que j'en ai vu,
et comme c'était quelqu'un
d'assez complexe...
De l'autorité, ça,
une fois qu'une décision
était prise, c'était pas
une base de négociation
pour d'autres personnes,
mais il écoutait beaucoup
avant.
Comme c'est quelqu'un
d'assez complexe,
en fait, je raconte
des facettes,
et puis chacun refera
son Mitterrand à partir
de ces différents
témoignages.
-Je rappelle
que ce livre sera publié
en janvier 2024.
-Chez Grasset.
-Julien Aubert,
vous avez publié
"Emmanuel le faux prophète".
Evidemment, c'est un Emmanuel
qui n'a rien à voir
avec le nôtre
ou c'est celui-là ?
-C'est le même !
-Ah.
-C'était l'idée
que les gens en 2017
ont découvert
ce personnage scintillant
et ont souvent vu la communication
qui allait avec,
et je dirais l'espoir
de quelqu'un
qui venait rénover
la vie politique
sans regarder son programme,
ses idées.
Je lui avais écrit
une lettre ouverte
le jour de son élection
en lui disant que
c'était fantastique pour lui,
mais que le jour
où les gens réaliseraient
là où il veut amener le pays,
je crains qu'ils le détestent
et que la violence
traverse son quinquennat.
Je l'avais mis en garde
sur le fait
que les électeurs
de Marine Le Pen
reviendraient par la fenêtre
sous une autre manière.
C'est un livre d'analyse
pour expliquer pourquoi
je ne suis pas macroniste
et pourquoi c'est l'inverse,
à mon avis,
de ce qu'a été le gaullisme.
-Merci.
Je voudrais rappeler
un ouvrage
que je trouve important
d'Henry Kissinger,
"L'ordre du monde",
chez Pluriel.
Evidemment,
c'est du Kissinger,
c'est-à-dire
que c'est brillant.
Il parle de l'ordre du monde
comme certains parlent
de leur goût pour la cuisine
ou les voyages.
Il me reste à vous remercier,
madame, messieurs,
d'avoir animé à mes côtés
cette émission.
Je voudrais remercier
l'équipe de LCP
qui est toujours là,
fidèle et compétente
pour faire de ces émissions
des moments de débat.
Avant de nous quitter,
je voudrais vous soumettre
ce jugement
ou cette pensée
d'Arnaud Teyssier :
"Il y a
un contraste saisissant
"entre une fonction
présidentielle omniprésente
"et une forme d'impuissance
et de résignation."
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA